fibromyalgia is a chronic or
long-lasting condition it causes muscle
and joint pain all over your body
the exact cause of fibromyalgia is
unknown but it may be a problem with how
your nerves and brain sense pain signals
people with fibromyalgia are much more
sensitive to sensory experiences such as
pressure heat or cold bright light and
noise compared to people without
fibromyalgia
things that may increase your risk for
it are a family history of fibromyalgia
physical or emotional trauma and stress
having certain diseases such as
rheumatoid arthritis or lupus
having anxiety and depression
being female
and being middle-aged or older
common symptoms of fibromyalgia include
body pain and tenderness
feeling very tired problems sleeping
thinking and memory problems known as
fibro fog and headaches
other symptoms may include tingling or
numbness in the hands and feet mental
health problems such as anxiety or
depression
and digestive problems such as irritable
bowel syndrome or gastroesophageal
reflux disease
since there is no cure for fibromyalgia
treatment for it focuses on relieving
your symptoms
treatments may include medications
Lifestyle Changes
and Psychotherapy or talk therapy
medications your health care provider
May prescribe to help reduce pain and
improve sleep include
antidepressants and anti-seizure
medicines
you may also be advised to take
over-the-counter anti-inflammatory pain
relievers but fibromyalgia doesn't cause
inflammation so they often aren't
helpful for fibromyalgia pain
certain lifestyle changes can help you
manage Fibromyalgia symptoms these
include getting enough sleep
regular exercise and staying active
and eating a healthy diet
the goal of talk therapy is to help you
change the way you think or act
it can help you learn ways to cope with
your symptoms and provide you with
support
to find out more about fibromyalgia talk
to your healthcare provider